c'est ainsi tout est expliqué et somme
de proprement tiko from dust from
français à tous les jours je travaille
toujours avec coeur plein de gens de
différentes heures de grandes
professions et ces gens leur but c'est
de trouver des idées mais ces idées là
souvent ce sont des idées qui vont vivre
dans c'te c'est bon c'est pas des idées
que tu prennes l'essence même lorsqu'on
travaille par exemple en date en
conscience ce sont des idées qui
tranquillement thauvette avec le travail
que tout le monde puisse prendre un
emploi et vivant seul nous tous les
choses qu'on fait savidan futur pour moi
les créatifs ce sont les gens qui va et
qui maintenant la salle crois que vous a
décrit ainsi fleuri est ce que vous
sentez créatif pour tous
ah oui oui bien sûr loin
moi je peux vous dire que tous des
créatifs
le problème que vous avez vous aussi
vous en savez pas comment amplifier
votre voix créative donc aujourd'hui ce
que je vous donnais lors de l'es4 truc
branchez votre voix critiques parce que
souvent les idées
ces choses qui sont fragiles ce soir
c'est difficile d'avoir des idées
souvent lorsqu'on a une idée on veut la
garder
on vend l'instant du calepin ont la
garde près de nous parce qu est ce qu un
nouveau bébé on veut pas donner l'idée
parce que si on donnait à quelqu'un
invente écran de l'argent avec
ou peut-être qu'ils volaient à changer
le décor et finalement on les mobilités
au contraire les idées il faut les
partagent souvent j'ai remarqué
aujourd'hui en sciences lorsque les gens
ont des idées on les partage les idées
deviennent réalité parce que la
collectivité que les sports comme un
france aux qualités
harry l'innovation arrive parfois les
idées fortes et nabeul est grande d
amplifier donc la première chose qu'ils
font se dire lorsqu'il faut amplifier
une idée c'est le contexte
prenez votre idée positive et la
question dans quel contexte favorise
souvent les gens lorsqu'ils ont une idée
ils ont les déjantés fiers ils peuvent
pas dire exactement futur où l'idée
d'apprendre d'essence par exemple les
gens qui ont créé facebook les gens qui
crient facebook
la majeure partie des gens ce sont les
programmeurs mais aussi des os design
ces gens dû souvent se pose la question
dans quel contexte les gens vont
utiliser mon jeu
dans quels contextes et les genres en
tournoi interfacé avec l'information
mais tout ça est dans un contexte si par
exemple vous faites quelque chose
bonne idée et l'idée l'offre en essence
pour jeux olympiques en 2020 aussi
validé reprendre demain matin lorsque il
va pleuvoir les des change complètement
posez vous la question actif pour que
vous avez une idée dans quel contexte se
vider leurs veaux juifs
comment les gens vont la percevoir est
ce que cette idée lors est pertinent
dans le contexte souvent ce qu'on le dit
dans ce post pc keystone aux assises
avait un petit peu dit notant qu'elle
propose et à ce titre alicante et chaud
si l'idée n'est pas pertinent dans un
moment les dévorer poursuivant je trouve
que only fausse bonne idée
souvent on pense qu'on a une bonne idée
et puis on travaille dessus
on met de l'argent de l'énergie puis en
boule et on s'aperçoit que l'idée aux
bonnes mais souvent c'est parce que
c'est par un contexte une bonne idée
souvent reprend toute sa pertinence dans
mon père mon deuxième point c'est la
culture les idées sera naissent de la
culture sera les gens se nourrissent
leurs cris de leur processus de création
par la culture
et puis par la suite cessé dès leur
retour n'en a qu'une
ces idées là forment la culture cette
même attaque de société explose
et puis on est des archéologues qui on
cherche qu'est ce qui se passe après
vingt ans de guerre nucléaire on sort
des artefacts de de publicité de
panneaux d'emballage de produits on
réalise que on line dont le portrait le
futur donc souvent ce qu'ont fait nos
idées dans ce collier de culture lorsque
le cri la campagne de distance mais pour
le dire pour célébrer les salir les 50
ans de l'originalité de distance pour
lui d'aller chercher une vieille chanson
de 1950
et puis on la verrait la saveur à la
saveur d'aujourd'hui faire en sorte que
nos idées sont portés par la culture
sont amplifiés par la culture
à toutes les fois qu'on a une bonne idée
coli ce petit peu de culture alentours
vous allez voire l'amplification de
cette idée là très rapidement les gens
consomment ans apprendront la parthenay
quelques années on avait fait une
campagne pour les droits aura plus
l'équipe de l'as fait pas souvent les
gens avaient pas l'impression de faire
partie de cette équipe là on est d'avis
qu'avec un petit slogan oui de noir
les gens ont tellement à derry par la
culture à 720 globe car rapidement les
gens se sont fait des drapeaux sont
tatoués sur leur corps et koné du mans
ce comité présidé par paul partout sur
la rue ça c'est lorsque la culture
sinon et des votes ont remis leur mort
est capable a assuré nick edel est
pertinente dans un contexte et de nuit
la résonance par la suite à la culture
et des fois c'est une question de qu'est
ce que je peux mettre alentours de monde
et pour la faire exploser paraît plus
dure et la culture peut supporter cette
idée là à l'extérieur des frontières
contre 11,1 points c'est vrai que ça
pour moi c'est la chose la plus
importante
présentement ici on m'a dit de venir sur
le petit tapis rouge
ok mais si je décide de sortir du tapis
rouge
la scène les caravanes parce que nous
sommes tous je me suis sûr est enviée
m'asseoir ici à voter l'on indique si on
n'a pas la même province a si on n'a pas
la même présentation
moi je suis toujours à m'écrire un peu
importe ce que vous faites vous devez
viser quelque chose juste prix - nous
regarde pas d'idées
regardez ce que vous faites et puis
qu'est-ce qui arrive qui brise une chose
lorsque steve jobs a inventé l'art est
pas pourquoi qui a décidé de n'être
blanc pour kaka liste de m les écouteurs
blâme tout le monde qui trônaient des
époux temps mort et lui a décidé de
mettre des tables et breezy une chose
pourquoi lorsqu'on rentre dans un hôtel
on est obligé d'avoir leur la porte
d'entrée on rente la réception le
concierge abu dis pourquoi on est obligé
d'avoir pour quand on peut pas bâtir un
hôtel
complètement seul regardez à tous les x
lorsque vous travaillez dans un
j'ai peu importe la discipline prenez du
temps
arrêtez vous qu'est-ce qu'on peut change
une chose qu'on peut changer
est-ce qu'on peut changer la forme la
couleur le contexte le messages
des fois c'est changer de message dans
le contexte dans lequel on est des fois
c'est changer le format souvent
lorsqu'on consomme la publicité on était
du devoir des messages 30 secondes est
l'été qui arrive si on fait un
documentaire
qu'est-ce qui arrivent sont fermés sage
de 5 secondes et ce car ils sont faits
des messages de deux vont changer les
choses comme ça ça fait toute la
différence au monde bien souvent on le
perd de façon c'est le rythme puisque de
chose de quelqu'un ou des visites
nombreux notre asso qui peut pas
facturer des lois par rapport à son bras
droit de faire ce que l'on revienne à la
nature on revit ce constat qui rouge
c'est important de sortir de sa zone de
confort de briser ces choses sinon vous
ne serez jamais différents
cette idée ne sera pas différent
lorsqu'on sort et on change une chose
non seulement nos d'idées devient
différent de vie unique de plusieurs
années j'ai travaillé avec arme et a
dansé un créateur très important avec
ses robes à volants robert m'a montré
comment changer la perception des gens
en défendent exemple une ou deux titres
aux amoureux on avait travaillé sur un
projet que c'était le moulin à images et
imaginons à québec pour célébrer les 400
ans
au québec on aurait pu faire un
spectacle on aurait pu faire un film on
aurait pu faire une parade un spectacle
non on a décidé de projeter un film sur
des silos à grains ne s'était jamais
fait voir un film extérieur sur une
grande surface architectural on est à
l'abri existera une chose et ça fait
toute la différence donc rapide ou deux
ans au risque gros la 4e dire une
facture qui d'après moi est la chose la
plus importante sont faire quelque chose
tu es qui va rester à munich
souvent lorsqu'on travaille une idée
lorsqu'on travaille un produit un projet
selon les principales à cela on le des
contraintes technologiques souvent des
fois on est des contraintes budgétaires
et puis on pousse pas de travail
jusqu'au bout moi je suis toujours à les
épier rafting stone faut prendre le
temps de bien faire les choses parce que
les idées c'est lorsqu'on 1,26 dollar à
un niveau artistique quelle idée damas
que la beauté de rentrer en ligne de
compte lorsque vous voyez un spectacle
par exemple seraient quatre seules
vacances au soleil
oui c'est un spectacle circassien une
scène de déjà mais qu'est ce qui fait en
sorte que la réputation du sol elle a
fait le tour du monde ces patients est
facturé
pour le monter le niveau de l'expérience
à un niveau artistique qu'est ce qui
fait que l'expo 67 de montréal les
billets sphère est devenu qu'on a ce
qu'on veut monter au niveau de l'art une
structure architecturale tout ce qu'on
fait lorsqu'on pousse un peu plus dans
la réalisation de la pièce devient
soudainement un niveau d'arnaud
artistique et lorsque ces choses avec ce
niveau là tout devient pertinent les
choses qu on est mort on veut les danses
et les idées que son probable les idées
sont inspirants en veritas et les idées
qu'ils ont pour changer la société
en vérité ces déductions pour pertinents
au quotidien on peut les enlever parce
que ça fait du tout
mais les bucks d'être importants disent
des banquiers l'ont fait sont bien
rachetés que ces quatre points la halle
en vo c'est la mort est capable de créer
et changement et faire les bons débuts
chez sid lee
on travaille constamment avec des idées
dans nos matches on s'est revus en
avançant plein d'informations françois
pinault cité soleil ont bâti l oif début
on va se démarque un jour fait partie
des voitures j'espère et pour moi c'est
important c'est de progresser car
d'aplomb pour faire en sorte et visité
dix ans parce que si on crée des choses
ne font pas la différence
ça vaut pas la peine de faire souvent ya
déjà une voix avec des idées puis-je m
fausse bonne idée qui vont juste alors
dire les choses et si on rentre en
france au travers de ces quatre points
là on faire en sorte de nous laissons
nos produits et tout ce qu'on fait est
une expérience beaucoup plus grand
regret la différence en beauté donc je
vous laisse à du sort disguise du 8 mars
est-ce que ce soit vous faites et ce
soit pertinent et surtout différent
merci